on a joué depuis et puis c'est en mairie
que je gagne il fait tout vous avez
gagné le championnat de france vous est
présentée aux championnats du monde vous
avez terminé deuxième pour fait plus que
ça comme un pareil je suis allé un mardi
à la foire et quand ils ont vu combien
de points je faisais et qui avait le
championnat de france le samedi ils
envient téléphoné à paris
et puis nous disons organisé le voyage
l'hôtel et puis la place au concours que
j'ai remporté le samedi pour gagner ce
qui nécessite une certaine intelligence
retrouver le truc se trouvait la conduit
de l'ordinateur la commune du programme
[Musique]
allemand qui a gagné il était depuis
quelques mois déjà dans un club genevois
n'était pas un club en effet les
amateurs
maintenant je pense que
les jeux ils sont beaucoup plus
sophistiqué 1 et les gars ils sont
entraînés et puis en plus ils sont
jeunes ils sont ils sont plus vifs
[Musique]
bon vous êtes jeunes vous êtes bien
portants vous avez l'air sensés
relativement intelligents et vous jouez
à des jeux que d'aucuns qualifieront de
stupide pourquoi pourquoi pour les
divers cours quand on ne fait pas ça à
longueur de journée c'est pas abouti
sans sel et c'est abrutissant si on fait
plus que ça
[Musique]
j'ai pas le temps
j'ai fait ma la retraite j'ai eu au
téléphone oui